how to start a magazine with no money
there's a limited belief that holds a
lot of entrepreneurs back and that is I
need to have X amount of dollars to
start this business or won't be
successful and what it does is until you
get that money you don't do anything and
you just sit on your idea and as a
result you see other people making huge
cash off of what you are supposed to be
doing listen the money is not coming and
you don't need the money to be
successful you look at some of the most
successful entrepreneurs in the world
they started with nothing 20 bucks
they started their business you don't
need lots of resources you just need to
be resourceful and you need to do
something you need to get the idea out
of your head I actually start doing
something because everybody has an idea
and you're always going to be that guy
who looks at somebody else was
successful and said see how he made
millions that should have been me the
difference between him and you is he
took action I got a question for one of
my one of my Facebook fans love you guys
Facebook France
Alvarez Joe Joe Alvarez anyway wrote in
to say he's trying to start a magazine
as a student wants to start a magazine
wants to know how can he get this
started without money doesn't need to
have money to launch this thing this is
a great question and you starting it
from the right point of view how can I
start this business this magazine
without money the way to get started is
don't think about all the costs that you
have take about what you can do with
what you have right don't think about
the money you don't have think about
what you can do with what you have start
online make a website whatever content
you put in your magazine put it on the
website you don't know how to make a
website start it on facebook start
creating content that gets people
excited I've had lots of offers from
companies who wanted to turn my website
into a magazine I haven't had the right
offer that I'm comfortable with
and magazine has not been my top
priority but I could have turned it into
one if I wanted to that was my goal what
happened and the website to get a
website started is almost nothing right
a hosting cost a little bit domain name
a little bit but it's almost nothing to
get this started what you need to do is
build a following get people interested
in this so that when you are able to go
on launch your magazine you're not going
to blow your brains out on your cost and
not have anybody actually buying it or
buying ads in it build a following why
do people want to partner with me to
make a magazine because I have an
audience it's not just the content it's
the audience if I said here's the Evan
Carmichael magazine people would go out
and read it and buy it and advertise in
it because I have a following so
whatever your magazine is about whether
whatever your concept is start building
a following start practicing start
creating great content you're going to
get better you're going to increase your
skills your writing skills you're
publishing skills your editing skills
your recruitment skills to bring people
on board you're going to do all this in
a really low cost environment while
you're building a following so that when
you're ready to go launch a magazine
when you have people who are interested
in this when you can take your following
to them you have an audience you have
the skills you have the network to make
this thing successful and give you the
highest chance of turning this into the
magazine of your dreams so think big
here's our big picture here's what my
magazine looks like that's the world I
want to create but I'm going to start
small I'm going to start small and do
something today I'm going to post
something on Facebook and then tomorrow
I'm going to do it again next day again
mix it again then I'm going to get my
own website build that up all working
towards your big picture don't be the
guy who just has this big picture and
says until I get my 5k 50k 500k
get there so I'm going to do nothing and
then blame the rest of the world for not
supporting you this is on you to go out
and make it happen believe for those are
watching like the video give it a thumbs
up below let me know what you think
leave a comment underneath you have a
question for me I'll answer it if you
leave a comment below subscribe to the
channel if you like what you're seeing
and you want to see more thank you so
much and I'll see you soon